ouais elle lance une campagne pour
sensibiliser les citoyens aux défis que
vivent les personnes immigrantes dans le
marché de l'emploi
à montréal le taux de chômage pour les
personnes nées au pays et de 4,7 pour
cent chez les immigrants qui sont ici
depuis au moins cinq ans et + 2 6 % chez
les immigrants récents c'est plus de 12%
le crabe rhin et le maire du
plateau-mont-royal responsables
économiques de la ville de montréal
bonsoir bonsoir
pourquoi le chômage des immigrants
récents puisse pas la première fois
qu'on montre ses statistiques pourquoi
il est plus élevé à montréal que les
autres recettes d'immigrants et que dans
les autres grandes villes canadiennes
comme toronto et vancouver est ce qu'on
est capable de l'expliquer c'est une
bonne question
quand on compare avec vancouver on voit
qu'à vancouver il ya quand même un grand
bloc d'immigrants qui proviennent de la
chine donc qui ont aussi que pour
trouver un emploi souvent ça nous prend
des réseaux et à montréal et migration
est très fragmentée donc on a plusieurs
groupes mais on n'a pas de groupe plus
importante donc une un des facteurs qui
expliquent ces l'accès à des réseaux qui
nous est dit en entrevue du travail un
autre élément important c'est la
francisation donc on sait que environ
50% des nouveaux immigrants qui arrivent
à montréal m ici pas complètement la
langue française donc évidemment
montréal c'est un enjeu pour s'intégrer
au travail un autre élément par contre
aussi s'est il est dans notre tête celui
là c'est les préjugés
donc on a encore des préjugés à montréal
peut-être plus important que dans les
autres grandes villes vous pensez
écoutez quand on regarde les données
objectives les la diplomation ici ou
ailleurs la reconnaissance des diplômes
c'est un enjeu similaire la
reconnaissance de l'expérience à
l'extérieur du pays sont en jeu
similaire donc on doit se poser la
question si on n'a pas un biais
systématique dans notre sélection des
employés et pourtant on n'arrête pas de
parler de rareté de main-d'oeuvre
et de dire c est pire ici qu'ailleurs à
un moment donné est ce que ça me fait
penser d'ailleurs est ce que ce petit
que le chômage montrent une réalité qui
ressemble à ce que le gouvernement du
québec dit c'est à dire qu'il faut mieux
sélectionner les immigrants pour qu'il
réponde davantage aux besoins du marché
du travail
les migrants qui sont ici les migrants
les nouveaux arrivants sont très
diplômés et à plus de 60 % et sont
choisis pour leur potentiel économique
donc ils sont déjà diplômés ils sont
déjà trop bien des gens du milieu des
affaires par exemple donc ils ont les
qualifications pour avoir un emploi donc
ça explique pas tout il ya vraiment il
se heurte à des portes qu'on nous pose
parce qu'on a peut-être campagne porte
fermée et pourtant ils sont qualifiés
ils ont 10 potentiel et sont motivés et
pourtant ils ont plus de difficultés et
on regarde dans les études on nous dit
que les employeurs disent même qu'ils
vont préférer embaucher une personne née
au québec qu'une personne n'ait à
l'extérieur même si la personne n'ait à
l'extérieur est mieux qualifié ça on
vérifie ce exactement
donc il y en a eu quand même là dessous
on a une perception que ça va être plus
facile même si cette personne est un peu
moins qualifiés ça va être plus facile
probablement de l'intégrer dans son lieu
de travail si elle est née ici donc
c'est ça c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
change un peu bon alors votre programme
s'appelle porte fermée vous le v10 ça
veut dire quoi
oui en fait la campagne qu'on lance en
ce moment s'appelle portes fermées parce
qu'on voulait vraiment on est habitué à
tant de portes ouvertes
oui et l'on voulait mettre l'accent sur
les portes les nombreuses portes sont
fermées à des gens qui arrivent ici qui
ont du potentiel qui veulent travailler
comme pas les portes à l'immigration l'a
absolument divine dans la nôtre a dit
que les employeurs on ferme les malades
on ferme les portes à des gens qui ont
du potentiel qui pourrait contribuer
positivement au développement de notre
entreprise est ce qu'on veut faire c'est
de mobiliser la communauté notamment les
grands employeurs pour qu'on travaille
ensemble à trouver des solutions pour
ouvrir concrètement vous proposez quoi
qu'est-ce que comment on va y arriver
qu'est ce que vous proposez complètement
donc la stratégie porte fermée vise à
éveiller les consciences on veut que les
gens prennent conscience qu'ils ont un
problème donc on appelait en plus on est
dans un contexte vous l'avait nommé tout
à l'heure un contexte de rareté de la
main-d'oeuvre donc on pense que c'est
une bonne conjoncture pour essayer
d'ouvrir les portes parce que les
entreprises les ans pour tous les
employeurs
on a besoin d'avoir des gens qualifiés
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est en fait la
campagne de sensibilisation auprès des
employeurs et des employés et on va
travailler par la suite à l'engagement
des entreprises donc on a déjà une
quinzaine d'employeurs qui sont
mobilisés avec nous pour faire connaître
campagne là et on va développer des
outils pour les entreprises avec nos
employeurs partenaires pour être capable
de multiples outils réseaux type d outil
de sélection de la main d'oeuvre de voir
comment on fait nos processus de
sélection comment on s'assure qu'on
n'est pas biaisé dans nos processus de
sélection donc c'est vraiment des outils
très concrets de dotation de sélection
des des employés et de diffusion de nos
offres d'emploi peut-être dans des
réseaux où on voit pas habituellement
pour aller justement rejoindre des
personnes qui sont ici depuis moins
longtemps
il avoue parler d'une quinzaine
d'employeurs modèle un circle
d'employeur modèle c'est ça exactement
donc on un sac d'employeurs qui sont nos
partenaires les plus proches avec qui on
a travaillé et avec qui qui vont nous
aider à mobiliser et à faire connaître
la campagne auprès d'autres employeurs
au québec
oui bon mais on va suivre ça de très
près vous êtes maire du plateau montréal
depuis peu d'alliés qu'en place et luc
ferrandez vous êtes en charge depuis peu
aussi du développement économique votre
priorité c'est l'est de montréal ccem
vous avez dit avant les fêtes
pourquoi l'est de montréal écouter ça
fait des années qu'on parle du
développement de l'est de montréal
et en ce moment on a des astres qui nous
semblent alignés ce stade aucune volonté
ferme de la ville de montréal de
soutenir le développement de l'est et
des engagements du gouvernement du
québec
il ya déjà un engagement de 100 millions
pour la décontamination des terrains on
a des axes de transports collectifs qui
sont annoncés en chantier et on a
grandement fédérale qui devrait aussi
être au rendez vous et on a une
communauté qui est très mobilisé donc on
pense que c'est maintenant qu'on peut
faire le développement de l'ess et qu'on
peut se servir de l'est comme un exemple
de requalification d'un territoire avec
une vision de transition écologique de
qualité de vie et des milieux
résidentiels qui est ce que vous pensez
des demandes des milieux d'affaires
comme la fci qui dit que ça nous prend
une politique d'allègement illustratif
réglementaire beaucoup de locaux vacants
par exemple où est donc la vitalité
commerciale c'était ma deuxième priorité
que j'ai annoncée
en décembre donc on sait que le commerce
est en transformation partout dans le
monde
on a déjà réduit les charges fiscales
des commerçants l'année dernière on a
réduit la taxe sur le premier 500 me de
la valeur foncière pour les commerçants
cette année on l'augmenté assez 125000
donc on touche une très grande partie
des commerçants donc on fait de
l'allégement fiscal des commerces ont
fait déjà ça on a développé un programme
artères en chantier dont carrière des
grands chantiers on soutient les
commerçants donc on a déjà plusieurs
mesures en place et une commission en ce
moment sur les locaux vacants ou
entendre vraiment de d'identifier les
problèmes liés aux locaux vacants pour
éventuellement et ça ça va être ma
responsabilité comme élu responsable du
développement économique de mettre en
place des solutions pour soutenir les
commerçants n'en parlera d'ailleurs
quand ça arrivera
luc lavoie et merci beaucoup merci bien
aussi bien